[Music]
let's go
to the phones let's talk to michael
in dayton ohio what's up michael what's
going on man
hi john how are you i'm outstanding
brother how are you
how are you doing well good mama taught
me that you couldn't have kept me until
you're 18
so
awesome man so what's up um so i was
calling so a little background
i grew up in a uh evangelical christian
family
and um grew up in the distance from that
and now
i have a girlfriend who's jewish and
just difficulties of explaining that to
my parents and
navigating that so you say like so
you're not you're not
practicing christian anymore not
particularly
okay cool so then you met somebody who's
jewish and have you talked to your
parents about it have you not told them
what's the deal with that
so i have mentioned that but i haven't
really told my parents that
i'm not practicing religiously i just
kind of always felt like i could at
least performatively
maintain a religion just to uh maintain
peace in the household
so um how's that working out for you
um definitely causes a little bit of uh
tension for myself yeah the more
you have to perform or be dishonest
or lie to your parents in order to keep
the peace
the more that will leak out in other
areas and counseling used to call it
um leakage which is sounds like it's a
dirty diaper it kind of is
actually but it will find its way out it
just
usually comes out in real inopportune
times right it'll come up in some huge
blowout
or they'll find out and then suddenly
they'll realize you lied to them for 10
years and
departures in their pear tree right so
um
when you say like they kind of know what
does that mean
so i have mentioned to uh parents that
she's jewish and um that matters to her
and i've just kept on
mom's thought that oh you know she'll
become a christian too
eventually and it'll work itself out
that way
i think the way i could phrase it
so how can i help what are you asking me
um i think for me the um
challenge is how to approach
this while maintaining a relationship
with my parents and also
to this happened a long time before i
met my girlfriend i don't want my
parents
disliking her and seeing her as the
reason why
what happened that's exactly dude you're
a wise man so
um the longer you put off this
conversation the more
their existential angst of your
um choice of religious practice or
non-religious practice
will be dumped on her
and so i i is this somebody you're gonna
marry you're gonna spend your time with
her
you like this girl absolutely okay
that's awesome so
here's here's what you got to do man i
don't see a way around it
and how old are you i'm a 27 right now
yeah i think it's
a i know people in their 40s i know
someone who's almost
50 who will
say things like hey like hey don't tell
my parents but
and i'm thinking dude you're 40 what are
you like what are they going to do you
know they're gonna grab like
what kind of weird stuff is going so
you're 27 man you're a professional
you're grown up you're about to get you
know married
i think it's time to take them out
right you're carrying a bag of bricks
here every time you're with them you're
not able to fully be yourself and i do
think there's a
before i tell you what i think like what
i would do if i'm in your situation
what i have done if i'm in in your
situation just with different things
is this there's a difference between
being authentic
and not being dishonest and then there's
a
but you can do that and then there's
just being an idiot being a jerk
right so the difference of being
sitting down and saying hey listen um
i love you guys i want y'all to
know that i'm so grateful for the house
i grew up and i'm so grateful for you
too
i know and honor your christian faith
i haven't been there for years and
it's not anything you all did you didn't
screw anything up
where i am right now in my life that's
not a part of my life
and i want you to know i still carry
with me the lessons of character i still
carry the lessons of how to treat people
right with dignity and all those things
that they taught you right
um and i want you to expect them
to be heartbroken about that if they
truly have a religious belief that they
are
staked in the ground as is the truth and
the right way
and partridge into pear tree um they
they should be disappointed right they
should be heartbroken about that
and let them know i want to keep our
relationship strong
i want to continue to be here and then
this is where the respect part comes in
that's when you don't bad-mouth them for
going to church
that's when they if your mom says hey
when you're when you come visit us
we'd like you to come with us that you
can go right
if it becomes offensive and
heartbreaking then that's a whole other
conversation but
does that make sense there's a balance
between being honest and then being an
idiot
absolutely yeah i've like i i still in a
way see religious good just not some of
the exclusivity parts
okay so that's question that's
conversation number one
and i think you have it at the same time
the next part of that
is i really love this girl
the jewish faith is a big part of her
life
i want you to know that she's gonna be a
part of my life i hope so much she can
be a part of y'all's life too
i want i have these pictures in my head
of
our christmases and our um teaching
teaching you guys what hanukkah looks
like i've got these pictures of what
thanksgiving
all the different you know whatever's
i'm just making up as we go here
but um i want you all to know the
expectation won't be that
i'm gonna turn her into something that
she's not
and i hope that you guys will still love
her just like you would
my any other wife that i brought home
and then here's where it's hard for you
brother they get to choose what they do
next
they do they get to choose and they can
say
then we disown you we hate you you're
not our son anymore i don't think that's
going to happen
that happens all over the world by the
way but i don't think that's going to
happen with you
they are going to have a season of
mourning they may want to take you out
again and talk to you about it they may
send you books and tracks and
all of that is them trying to do the
best they can to love you in the ways
that they know how
right and so if you can
it may be annoying it may be frustrating
maybe whatever but it's him just trying
to love you
and if you can honor them by letting
them love you even if it's
in weird ways then so be it um but they
get to decide what they do next and
that's the hard part of any sort of
relational
truth-telling right it is
you seem nervous that you're going to
lose them do you think they're going to
bail on you
i i don't think so it's just i know that
i'm going to be the different one from
the rest of my family
and you've always been a different one
michael
haven't you yes i have
yeah see it's nothing new you're just
calling it out
that is true i think sometimes it's just
i think you have this conversation
sooner rather than later um you're gonna
it won't
feel good but you will be lighter you'll
move to the world lighter
you'll be able to look your mom and your
dad in the eyes and know that they're
telling the truth
and if you do this in a respectful
dignified and honorable way
and not choose to go to war because
you're uncomfortable
um man that's that's the best way to
treat people with dignity
i love you and i care about you and i've
come to some different conclusions in my
life
and i'm going to continue to love you
and honor you and be respectful
and i'm asking you guys to give me that
same honor and respect
and dignity back right and by the way
you're
about to get a new daughter-in-law and i
hope you will love her and
be hospitable to her and invite her in
your home and learn and ask questions
and and tell her tell your your
soon-to-be fiancee soon to be wife
hey man we're just gonna we're gonna
teach we're gonna love we're gonna learn
my parents are gonna stumble through
this for a while
and we're all gonna be on the same team
my brothers and sisters are gonna
stumble through this and figure it out
but we're all gonna be doing this
together right that's how
messy family disagreements
plus different beliefs plus all the
stuff
can endurance end up sitting around a
table all eating
all sharing all still loving loving each
other
even though we end up on same on
different sides of issues
religion's a tough one man but michael
be honest be truthful be yourself and be
respectful brother
that's the best you can do right now all
right hey thank you so much for your
call